>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
JOE BIDEN WENT ON TELEVISION
THIS AFTERNOON AND TALK TO THE
COUNTRY ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
HE SAID AMONG OTHER THINGS THAT
WE HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO LEAVE IN
ON THAT QUESTION, HE IS RIGHT.
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD HAVE
LEFT AFGHANISTAN FOR 19 YEARS
AGO WHEN IT BECAME OBVIOUS USAMA
BIN LADEN WASN'T THERE AND HAD
FLED TO PAKISTAN.
NO REASON TO STAY IN THE COUNTRY
AND THE LONGER WE REMAIN, THE
WORSE IT WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE.
THE QUESTION IS IN THE RELEVANT
QUESTION TODAY IS HOW EXACTLY DO
YOU GET OUT?
JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IS
NECESSARY DOESN'T MEAN YOU GET
TO IGNORE THE DETAILS OF IT.
AN EMERGENCY APPENDECTOMY, WOULD
IT MATTER TO YOU WHO PERFORMED
THE OPERATION?
YES, IT WOULD MATTER TO YOU.
BUT IT DIDN'T MATTER TO
JOE BIDEN, HE BARELY MENTION THE
WITHDRAWAL TODAY, BITE INTO THE
NECESSARY THING IN THE UGLIEST
POSSIBLE WAY.
YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING TELEVISION,
YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN THIS
FOOTAGE THAT TERRIFIED MEN AND
SANDALS CLINGING TO THE SIDES OF
A C17 AS IT ATTEMPTS TO LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN.
THIS IS THE ICONIC PHOTO OF THE
MOMENT.
THE FINAL SCENE OF THE AMERICAN
OCCUPATION OF AFGHANISTAN.
THAT MEANS AFTER 20 YEARS AND
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS, READERS
COULDN'T MANAGE TO PULL OFF AN
ORDERLY RETREAT.
THEY COULDN'T EVEN SECURE A
SINGLE RUNWAY.
AND THAT'S THE MAIN LESSON OF
THE FALL, WE ARE LED BY
BUFFOONS.
WE KNOW THAT NOW, THEY ARE
IMPOSTERS.
EVERYTHING THEY TOUCH TURNS TO
CHAOS NOT JUST THEY ARE BUT
HERE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO RUN THE
AMTRAK STATION IN DOWNTOWN
MANHATTAN THAT IS FILLED WITH
DRUG ADDICTS, PEOPLE IN CHARGE
OF THE POWER GRID OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND HAVE NO USEFUL
SKILLS YET SOMEHOW THESE PEOPLE
ASSURED US THEY WOULD TURN STONE
AGE AFGHANISTAN TO MODERN
BELGIUM.
REMEMBERING IT NOW IS BITTER AND
HILARIOUS.
AT THIS POINT, OUR LEADERS ARE
SO DISCREDITED THEY ARE RUNNING
OUT OF WAYS TO CRITICIZE THE
TALIBAN.
IS THAT BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REALLY GOING TO ATTACK THE NEW
GOVERNMENT OF AFGHANISTAN FOR
FORCING WOMEN TO COVER THEIR
FACES?
ARE AMERICAN DIPLOMATS ACTUALLY
GOING TO LECTURE TALIBAN LEADERS
ABOUT TOPPLING STATUES?
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT'S HOW MUCH CREDIBILITY OUR
LEADERS HAVE LOST, HOW MUCH
MORAL AUTHORITY THEY HAVE
SQUANDERED IN THE PAST 20 YEARS.
BUT MOST OF WHAT THEY'VE LOST IS
THERE SELF-AWARENESS.
JUST THIS WEEKEND, THEY HAD NO
IDEA HOW BADLY THEY WERE FAILING
IN AFGHANISTAN.
HERE IS JOHN KIRBY AT THE
PENTAGON EXPLAINING EVERYTHING
IS UNDER CONTROL.
KEEP IN MIND WE HAVE NOT EDITED
THIS TAPE AND IS NOT FROM LAST
YEAR.
THIS IS THREE DAYS AGO.
>> IT IS NOT RIGHT NOW IN
IMMINENT THREAT ENVIRONMENT.
>> Tucker: GOOD JOB, JOHN
KIRBY.
OF COURSE HE WILL KEEP HIS JOB.
A MAN WHO IS WILLING TO DEFEND
PREGNANT FIGHTER PILOTS CAN WORK
IN WASHINGTON FOREVER AND SO CAN
THE REST OF THE WOKE CLOWNS AT
THE PENTAGON, MUCH MORE WORRIED
ABOUT WHITE RAGE IN
WEST VIRGINIA THAN OUR ENEMIES
ABROAD.
SERIOUSLY, THEY HATE IT WHEN YOU
ASKED THAT QUESTION, NOTHING
BOTHERS THEM MORE BUT WHAT IS
THE ANSWER?
AND WHILE WE'RE AT IT, HOW ABOUT
THE INTEL AGENTS?
GIVE POLICYMAKERS SOME ROUGH
SENSE OF WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE
WORLD ESPECIALLY IN THE BIG
QUESTIONS TO MAKE WISE
DECISIONS.
HOW IS THE WORLD DOING ON THAT?
LET'S SEE.
THE COLLAPSE OF THE
SOVIET UNION, 9/11, NOT SMALL
THINGS, MAJOR HISTORY CHANGING
EVENTS.
THEY HAD NO IDEA.
SO WHY ARE THEY STILL THERE?
SOMEONE HAS TO READ YOUR TEXT
MESSAGES AND MAKE SURE YOU ARE
NOT MAKING FUN OF TRANS PEOPLE
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
THEN THERE'S THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OVERSEEING ALL OF
IT STAFFED BY POWER-HUNGRY
NONENTITIES.
HUBRIS DOESN'T DESCRIBE THE VIBE
OF THE CURRENT WHITE HOUSE, MORE
GRANDIOSE THAN THAT WHEN THERE'S
FAR JUSTIFICATION FOR IT.
HERE'S THE LEADING NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR, AS FAR AS WE
CAN TELL, HAS NEVER HAD AN
ACTUAL JOB.
OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL, HAS NO
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHATSOEVER.
WATCH THIS HIGHLY RESPECTED
SCHOLAR EXPLAINED THAT
EVERYTHING YOU WERE SEEING ON TV
FROM AFGHANISTAN IS A VICTORY.
>> HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN GETTING
THIS SO WRONG?
>> FIRST, TO BE FAIR, THE
HELICOPTER HAS BEEN THE MODE OF
TRANSPORT FROM THE END TO
EMBASSY TO THE AIRPORT FOR THE
LAST 20 YEARS.
>> THAT'S NOT THE MECHANISM.
YOU KNOW THAT, IT'S A LAST
MINUTE SCRAMBLE WHEN THIS WAS
NOT WHAT WE ARE GOING TO SEE.
>> THE REASON THEY WERE U.S.
FORCES AT THE AIRPORT
EFFECTUATING A SUCCESSFUL DRIVE
DOWN OF OUR EMBASSY, SECURING
THE AIRPORT TO BE ABLE TO GET
OTHER PEOPLE OUT IS BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT PREPOSITION THOSE
FORCES IN THE GULF SO THEY COULD
BE MOVED IN RAPIDLY IN THE EVENT
THERE WAS A RAPID COLLAPSE.
>> Tucker: SO THEY ARE
EFFECTUATING A SUCCESSFUL
DRAWDOWN OF OUR EMBASSY SO
THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL IT WHEN YOU
BURN YOUR FILES, JUST
EFFECTUATING ANOTHER SUCCESSFUL
DRAWDOWN.
WE COULD GO ON, WE COULD TORTURE
YOU WITH THE FAILURES IN THE
DETAILS AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN
MENTIONED THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TONY BLINKEN, A MAN SO MEDIOCRE
YOU GASP WHEN YOU HEAR HIM
SPEAK.
CAN YOU REALLY BE THAT DUMB AND
RUN THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE?
YOU CAN.
IN THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES OF
AMERICAN FORMAL POLICY PROVE
THAT YOU CAN.
AFGHANISTAN IS NOT THE FIRST
COUNTRY IN OUR LEADERS HAVE LEFT
WORSE THAN THEY FOUND IT.
THE LIST OF THOSE COUNTRIES AS
LONG.
PART OF THE REASON IS FOR
DECADES, LEFT-WING ACADEMICS IN
THE U.S. HAVE USED THE
DEVELOPING WORLD AS A LABORATORY
TO TEST THEIR THEORIES ABOUT HOW
SOCIETIES OUGHT TO BE ORDERED
BUT AREN'T.
OVER TIME, THEY HAVE CONSTRUCTED
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF NGOs
THAT WORK ALONGSIDE THE PENTAGON
AND STATE DEPARTMENT'S TO IMPOSE
RADICAL SOCIALISM PROJECTS ON
THE WORLD'S POOREST PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NO SAY IN THE MATTER.
OVER THE LAST 20 YEARS FOR
EXAMPLE, CONGRESS HAS ALLOCATED
CLOSE TO A BILLION DOLLARS TO
EXPORT FEMINISM TO AFGHANISTAN.
WHERE DID THAT MONEY GO?
AND WENT TO A TWO YEAR'S MASTERS
DEGREE IN GENDER AND WOMEN'S
STUDIES OFFERED AT KABUL
UNIVERSITY.
ANOTHER U.S. GOVERNMENT EFFORT
WAS TO FIND ACTIVITIES THAT
EDUCATE AFGHAN MEN'S AND BOYS TO
CHALLENGE GENDER STEREOTYPES.
AND OF COURSE, ALWAYS AND
EVERYWHERE, LEADERS AND FORCE
THE MOST AMERICAN OF ALL
CULTURAL EXPORTS, AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION.
AMERICAN FUNDED GENDER ADVISORS
DEMANDING THAT WOMEN COMPROMISE
AT LEAST 10% OF THE AFGHAN
NATIONAL ARMY AND A STILL LARGER
PROPORTION OF THAT COUNTRY'S
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP THANKS TO
AMERICAN IMPOSE GENDER QUOTAS,
DOZENS OF WOMEN ULTIMATELY WERE
INSTALLED AS REPRESENTATIVES,
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
THE WHOLE THING WAS A SHAM AS
ALWAYS.
IN FACT, MANY OF THESE NEW
FEMALE LEGISLATORS HAD NEVER
BEEN TO THE PROVINCES THEY CLAIM
TO REPRESENT.
ALMOST NOBODY IN AFGHANISTAN
LIKED ANY OF THIS, BY THE WAY,
AND WHY WOULD THEY?
THERE IS ONE OFFICIAL CONCEDED
IN A CLASSIFIED REPORT,
"FOCUSING ON GENDER MAY MAKE
THINGS MORE UNSTABLE BECAUSE IT
CAUSES REVOLTS.
IT CAUSED REVOLTS.
BUT OFFICIALS KEPT DOING IT,
THEY KEPT PUSHING RADICAL GENDER
POLITICS ANYWAY BECAUSE THEY
COULD BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
CHARGE OF THESE PEOPLE THEY WERE
GOING TO EDUCATE.
THIS IS THE FACE OF THE LATE
AMERICAN EMPIRE, GENDER STUDIES
SEMINARS AT GUNPOINT FOR THIS IS
NOT LIKE OTHER EMPIRES.
UNLIKE OTHER EMPIRES, OUR SYSTEM
OPERATES FOR OUR BENEFIT.
THEY TOOK NO OIL, REMEMBER THAT?
INSTEAD, THE ENTIRE POINT OF OUR
IMPERIAL PROJECT IS TO GIVE
MEANING TO THE EMPTY LIVES OF
THE NEOLIBERAL.
WHAT ROLE DOES THE REST OF US
PLAY IN THIS?
NON, WE JUST PAY FOR IT.
YESTERDAY TO UNDERSCORE THAT
POINT, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TOLD US THAT AMERICAN CITIZENS
WOULD NOT BE GIVEN PRIORITY, SO
OUR GOVERNMENT'S OFFICIAL
POSITION IS THAT AMERICAN LIVES
ARE NOT MORE VALUABLE THAN THE
LIVES OF FOREIGNERS BUT YOU
ALREADY KNEW THAT BECAUSE YOU'VE
SEEN OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE PEOPLE WHO MADE THE AFGHAN
POPULATION POSSIBLE LIKE TO SEE
A LOT MORE OF OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, MUCH MORE UNRESTRAINED
IMMIGRATION AND BRING IN THE
REFUGEES TONIGHT.
THAT'S THE ONLY LESSON THEY ARE
TAKING FROM THIS DEBACLE.
"AMERICA MUST NOT STAND IDLY BY.
THE PRESIDENT MUST URGENTLY RUSH
TO DEFEND, RESCUE, GIVE AND
EXPAND, THERE IS NO TIME TO
SPARE.
THERE'S LOTS OF TIME TO SPARE AS
AMERICANS DIE OF FENTANYL ODs
AND FOREIGN NATIONAL IDENTITIES
LIVE HERE BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
BRINGING AFGHANS INTO OUR
COUNTRY, THERE IS NO TIME TO
SPARE AND LIZ CHENEY AGREES WITH
THAT ALONG WITH NANCY PELOSI AND
THE STATE DEPARTMENT, SO MANY
MORE, SO MANY MORE JUST LIKE
THEM.
THESE ARE THE ARCHITECTS OF THE
DISASTER WE ARE WATCHING UNFOLD
ON TELEVISION AND SHOULD BE
GROVELING FOR OUR FORGIVENESS,
BUT THEY ARE NOT.
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES DECENCY.
THERE'S NO CHANCE.
SO WE ARE GETTING IT AND IF
HISTORY IS ANY GUIDE AND IT'S
ALWAYS A GUIDE, WE WILL SEE MANY
REFUGEES FROM AFGHANISTAN
RESETTLE IN OUR COUNTRY AND OVER
THE NEXT DECADE, THAT NUMBER MAY
SWELL TO THE MILLIONS.
SO FIRST, WE INVADE AND THEN WE
ARE INVADED.
IT IS ALWAYS THE SAME.
WE WILL BE SPENDING A LOT MORE
TIME ON THAT SUBJECT IN COMING
WEEKS BECAUSE IT MATTERS BUT
FIRST, SINCE KABUL HAS JUST
FALLEN, MIGHT BE WORTH ASKING
THE MOST OBVIOUS QUESTION OF
ALL.
WHY DID THE TALIBAN WIN?
HOW DID THE SIXTH CENTURY
TRIUMPH OVER THE 21ST CENTURY?
THERE WERE INDICATIONS THAT THE
SINGLE MOST NOTORIOUS AND
REVILED GOVERNMENT IN THE WORLD,
PRIMITIVE PEOPLE FAMOUS FOR
THEIR BRUTALITY, RIGIDITY, AND
HUMORLESS NESTS ARE MORE POPULAR
IN PARTS OF AFGHANISTAN THAN
THEY WERE WHEN WE EXPELLED THEM
20 YEARS AGO.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO BE LESS
POPULAR, SO HOW DID THAT HAPPEN,
WHAT IS THE ANSWER?
LET'S NOT JUST BLOW PAST IT LIKE
THAT, WHAT IS THE ANSWER?
COUNTRIES ARE VERY COMPLICATED,
SO THERE ARE LIKELY MANY ANSWERS
BUT ONE OF THOSE ANSWERS MAY BE
THAT THE POPULATION OF
AFGHANISTAN HAS FIRMLY REJECTED
WHAT OUR LEADERS WERE SELLING IT
OVER 20 YEARS.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THE PEOPLE OF
AFGHANISTAN DON'T ACTUALLY WANT
GENDER STUDIES SYMPOSIUM.
THEY DIDN'T ACTUALLY BUY THE
IDEA THAT MEN CAN BECOME
PREGNANT.
THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS
RIDICULOUS.
THEY DON'T HATE THEIR OWN
MASCULINITY.
THEY DON'T THINK IT'S TOXIC,
THEY LIKE THE PATRIARCHY, SOME
OTHER WOMEN LIKE IT SO NOW THEY
ARE GETTING IT ALL BACK.
SO MAYBE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WE
FAILED IN AFGHANISTAN BECAUSE
THE ENTIRE NEOLIBERAL PROGRAM IS
GROTESQUE, IT'S A JOKE, IT'S
CONTRARY TO HUMAN NATURE, IT
ANSWERS NONE OF OUR DEEPEST
HUMAN DESIRES, IT IS MERELY A
PERFORMANCE STAGE FOR THE
PERFORMER, NOT EVEN SUPPOSED TO
IMPROVE YOUR LIFE.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
AN IDEA THAT RIDICULOUS AND ONLY
BE IMPOSED BY FORCE ONLY WITH
ARMED MEN AT GUNPOINT.
THE MOMENT THESE IDEAS ARE NOT
MANDATORY, PEOPLE TEND TO REVERT
TO THE LIVES THAT THEY REFE